drinking too much is bad ladies and
gentlemen so what's the plan for today
zero yeah
the good news is it's all downhill on
the way back I'm going to work on a new
book maybe the drama continues good job
[Music]
happy day for believe nation we are on
our way to contact Ilan which is the
entry way to get to Olympia to see the
ruins in the stadium stadium all the
stadium I don't know I think I made that
up I just leave last night me me me me
oh man it's gonna be one of those days I
just lost I mean not bad I mean I woke
up at 6 something this morning whatever
six something the clock went forward an
hour but it was really 6 o'clock because
she drank 18 glasses of wine last night
it's pretty close what was it it was at
least eight seven glasses of wine last
night I think the last fourteen forgot
and they woke me up I went to bed at
2:00 and then she woke me up
thinking stuff thinking right maybe
write another book I don't know crazy
crazy thoughts anyway
good good time should be a fun day so
we're gonna we're gonna get into the
tackle on tiny little city and then see
if we can share a cab with somebody or
otherwise find their way to Olympia
we're both congested why okay whatever
here we go holy cow that's a meal but
what the heck is that you don't like
sweet stuff you don't like meat creams
okay Nene tell us how it is sweet okay
oh listen the coffee gets a thumbs up
from Nina the food where is it the food
is just here the coffee's up here
alright Nene a good job
[Music]
we are here and it is hot we are melting
you know got a little bit sick in the
car right over the guy doing 130 driving
between two lanes I loved it
we got here in 20 minutes instead of 40
minutes it's the best but Nina's a
little carsick you're gonna feel okay
let's go see some ruins ruins its ruins
time so look at what they do with their
garbage this is pretty interesting they
have the garbage here and they have a
thin here just for the lids of the
bottle caps to recycle them or there's
some other reason for it I don't get it
not the entire bottle just the lids why
Greece educate me
[Music]
Nene made a very important realization
what do you want to tell us Nene what
did you just realize but what okay we
know you're great and she's not feeling
well she's not feeling well because too
much to drink
yes drinking too much is bad ladies and
gentlemen so what's the plan for today
zero zero all right well I might have
something because I drink responsibly
we hope Nina feels better in all
seriousness right Nina believe Nations
sending you love
[Music]
okay I promise Nina some calamari so
next stop is calamari time don't let us
down could tackle on this is it let's
see if they have it check the menu what
too hot inside alright sit here local
Greek beer okay give it a try Nina no
okay forget it
try the yogurt and honey the gyros has
arrived but the tomatoes on that okay
Runyan I love it great
they're a big kiss after okay let's go
how we doing mmm all right
thumbs up nice oh my gosh drivers will
shut up you know nice good job grease oh
that was a very satisfying meal how you
doing
you're walking kind of funny because my
legs aren't ready her legs are hurting
the seats weren't the most comfortable
but very satisfying meal good job to
tackle on we're fans thank you for the
love
okay next when we're doing we're gonna
explore this little town tick in the
local shops and then get a special
coffee
[Music]
we are climbing up a giant hill in the
heat to get to this coffee shop that
sells overpriced coffees but has an
amazing view we're going for the view
and our workout
we love you Nina keep pushing it's
straight uphill the good news is it's
all downhill on the way back
[Music]
is it closed
oh my god is it closed no this is
parking that's what the parking this
close to all man this is that
please be open me i Tammy me yet Timmy
please be open look at that
we can we made it Nina look at these
views
hello Kotak a lot
this is a good place to grab a coffee
with my beautiful wife
hello you need to relax
there's my Greek cappuccino I'm gonna
enjoy this and my amazing to you
[Music]
all right leaving the coffee place had
to go inside because there were a ton of
bees and they loved Nina they love
chasing Nina and it almost fell into my
mouth so that was enough for me to say
okay let's go inside but we enjoyed the
view we're gonna get back to the ship
not really gonna nap okay
Nina's gonna nap I'm going to work on a
new book maybe might happen happening
what's new book about finding your
purpose finding your purpose yeah
it's one of the most common questions
they get asked how to find your purpose
have helped so many people that I feel
like we gotta make it jump it into a
book anyway nice you guys should hope
that Nina takes an extra long nap so I
could finish the book while not
finishing but making a lot of progress
and I just discovered on my on our
airplane ride home there is no Wi-Fi so
that gives me time to work in the book
too yeah all right when we travel there
seems to be a lot of book writing we
should shovel more it'll make more books
we'll see anyway okay like to vote
[Music]
okay a couple of very important
announcements first off we feel great
Neiman did not nap though to just play
it on their phone so most of the time it
is elegant night in the dining room so
it's an elegant do you mean oh look at
me
hello that's that's what that's what
elegant dress looks like believe nation
second off there is extreme weather
coming to our area amazing and so
they're going to be shortening our
length of trip stay in Santorini
tomorrow and Athens the next day century
at the end of the world I guess depends
how much they shortlist them there's not
that much to do there except taking the
views have lunch but Greece at Greece
Jesus the whole thing is Greece Athens
is a big deal because it's like an hour
away from our stop because office is not
on the water so that really cuts into
our time so hopefully it's not that big
of delay we will see the drama continues
the charming gentleman the chemical
vacation continues yeah all right give
it time let's see what we got
drinks have arrived I am trying a
Belgian beer for the first time I've
never seen this one before
Annina decided to have a rose a she's
drinking again
she says one glass we'll see what
happens
Cheers appetizers are here I got the
escargot something the snails in there
and Nina's going healthy with a salad
doesn't look appetizing
I like the arugula though Nina got an
extra suit vegetables salted water Wow
okay well enjoy you
Nachi you like hot water now it's salted
us and vegetables main entree beef
that's that's pretty light actually
looking good Nina's guy what did you get
a lamb lamb all right I'm starting down
here
and
stay there all right all right near how
I'm feeling good
your legs are swollen sure my left leg
is sore my left calf is sore what did
you find in a Sudoku challenge ho
oh yeah snacks okay believe nation
herding back to the room you guys are
not invited if you want to see what we
did yesterday and read the scene check
out the link next to us I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe we'll see you there
inna hell's Brindisi so far make
lemonade from lemons that's that's the
plan for today